I have bad news when it comes to your
internet privacy we've been following
the Republican bill that sought to get
rid of internet privacy rules so that
Internet service providers would be
allowed to sell your personal browsing
history to advertisers I told you that
Congress the House of Representatives
voted down party lines
Republicans yes Democrats know to pass
the bill Republicans in the Senate voted
yes Democrats in the Senate voting no
which led to the Senate passing the bill
there was some speculation that maybe
Donald Trump would come to his senses on
this issue although that rarely happens
and veto this but Donald Trump indeed
signed the bill into law earlier this
week and before this point Internet
service providers had to get their
customers consent before doing anything
with browsing histories but now internet
service providers who already have a lot
of power and opportunities to coax money
out of people now they can do almost
anything they want with your browsing
history and people have been writing to
me saying David I'll just clear my
browsing history oh no no no no no this
is this is not about the locally stored
in your browser browsing history this is
the fact that your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit because after all you're
communicating to the Internet through
them and using Google Chrome is not
gonna work on this one
yeah incognito mode on Google Chrome is
not going to solve the problem and this
was another one of those congressional
reviews which have been allowing
Congress to undo regulations that were
put in place during and towards the end
of the Obama presidency before Donald
Trump became president this process had
been used once ever okay to undo a Bill
Clinton labor regulation in 2001 since
Donald Trump has been president
congressional Republicans have gone wild
with congressional reviews using this
mechanism eleven times to undo Obama era
regulations they say hey it's small
government really what he did what it is
is corporate power handouts and Craig
Aaron the CEO of the public advocacy
group Free Press friend of the show who
have known for years and who's been on
the show many times said to the hill
about this quote there is literally no
public support for this bill it's only
advocates are the nation
biggest phone cable and Internet
companies there's no longer any question
if there ever was whose needs this
administration intends to serve but
people everywhere are on high alert to
the serious threat to the free and open
Internet and they will fight back
I like that Craig mentions public
support for this imagine doing a public
poll for this bill do you want your
internet service provider to be allowed
to sell your browsing history to
advertisers without your consent
no I mean who would say yes that's
something that I want if asked publicly
you don't even have to imagine polls on
this because they're out there and I've
seen 6% and 11% support so that would
have to include plenty of Trump
supporters as well I would assume that
of the 11% who say that they're in favor
of this and I'd have to see how it was
worded half of them don't even
understand the question and which is
often an issue with polling which is you
have some percentage of people who don't
even get what it is that you're asking
about and I still don't see how not a
single Republican in either house of
Congress the House of Representatives or
the Senate could have said I'm gonna be
against this we know that many of these
elected officials have been influenced
significantly by the cable lobbies and
the industry Republicans have given the
pretext that oh well Google and Facebook
collect information on people so why is
it different if the ISP does it of
course people can choose not to use
Google or Facebook people can't choose
not to use an Internet service provider
how do you get on the Internet otherwise
maybe if you live in a place that has
municipal broadband but in most cities
there is no such option
Johnathan's palter who's the CEO of US
telecom it's an isp lobbying group brace
ourselves he said quote we welcome
president Trump's action today affirming
Congress's decision to hit the reset
button by stopping rules that would have
created a confusing and conflicting
consumer privacy network I love this
argument that's being made that before
the rules were confusing and now they're
not yeah before you might have thought
that maybe your browsing history
couldn't just be sold without your
consent to advertisers now you're no
longer confused Pat you have no privacy
and your browsing history can be sold
without your consent
advertiser's that's the argument some of
these defenders are making like now we
know that whatever website you look at
could be bought by advertisers finally
our day has come you know it's funny
usually when Donald Trump signs a bill
or an executive order yeah he does so in
public right photo-op and he shows off
the bill as if it's some sort of trophy
yeah this was done behind closed doors
oh you want anyone to know about this is
not one that he's having a big public
ceremony for this is not even one that
he'll do the ceremony for and then
forget to sign it and walk out
attracting even more attention to it as
we talked about earlier this week this
is one that they're not going to mention
Democrats need to be loud about this
okay on many issues
Republicans and Democrats very similar
on many issues Republicans and Democrats
couldn't be more different and in this
case it was a party line vote every
Democrat who voted in the House and
Senate voted against this this is
something that the sort of general even
people who aren't politically active
would pay attention to if they are loud
about the fact that Republicans and
Trump went out of their way to make it
so that your browsing history could be
sold this is just one example among what
will probably be many regressive
communications policies under Trump I've
told you before even though he doesn't
really seem to understand that Donald
Trump is against net neutrality
he once said net neutrality is the
Fairness Doctrine confirming that like
with many of the issues Trump has a
strong opinion on he doesn't know what
it is we've got to brace ourselves Pat
because the communications policy it's
gonna get really bad over the next four
years and the problem with him is if
he's ever ignorant on a certain issue
he'll just assume the position of his
closest advisors or whoever speaks to
him most recently right and when your
advisers are people like Steve Brannon
and Reince Priebus it's not a good sign
you say rights right I always get that
wrong I say rinse Priebus like I want to
rinse my hands of the insanity that is
Reince Priebus well who knows at this
point I always get criticized for
pronouncing words incorrectly my
favorite is when you refer to me LOI
innopolis yes dad I think is the best
one anyway we're actually gonna talk a
little bit more about what's going on
with Pat's pronunciation on the bonus
show today it could be Pat's fifth
controversy so far on the David Pakman
show